ein planet arag es ist so schön wenn die
sonne tief steht
wenn sie über dem sand schwebt kann man
das eis in der luft
heute geht es um das hier das ist ein
buch namens tunen auf deutsch der
wüstenplanet seit fünf jahren sind alle
sechs bände fantastisch übersetzt von
jakob schmidt und da geht es um einen
planeten in ferner zukunft auf dem
eigentlich nichts außer sand und würmer
und eine droge zu finden sind die würmer
sind zum teil bis zu 400 meter lang und
sehr großen sehr bedrohlich die droge
braucht man um die zukunft vorherzusehen
oder wahrscheinlichkeit zu sehen also
braucht man sie zum beispiel im
raumschiffe zu steuern und diese wüste
die es auf diesem planeten gibt die hat
sandstürme die so schnell sind mit
soviel kinetischer energie dass der sand
metall durchschlagen kann und das alles
sieht man diesen film wo es darum geht
dass ein junger mann der von nichts eine
peilung hatte auf diesem planeten kommt
und dort der messias wird das heißt er
hätte diesen planeten erwartet die firma
die die droge der verhindert nur noch
größere inflationsrate und weiß der
teufel was
ich kenne dich
etwas erwartet dieser film ist von
dennis wird das ist der mann der eifel
gemacht hat und blade runner 20 08 15
oder wie das heißt und er ist der
zweitbeste science fiction regisseur
aller zeiten des deswegen weil der platz
eins leer bleiben muss weil science
fiction handel von der zukunft und die
beste ist inzwischen regisseurin kommt
erst noch
für unseren die erwartung ist da das
ungefähr zwei drittel vom ersten von
sechs büchern sind die frank herbert
geschrieben hat dass wir da eine
filmreihe vor uns haben daher kommen die
vergleiche die man viel jetzt liest und
hört das ist das neue herr der ringe
dass das neue star wars das wird dem
inhaltlichen und auch dem technischen
auch den künstlerischen aspekt also drei
aspekten nicht so richtig gerecht herr
der ringe handelt davon wie man mit
unglaublichem aufwand eine welt
verteidigt gegen die böse künftige welt
mit ganz viel technik und ganz viel
kälte also die kleinen hobbits da mit
ihrem gras und mit ihren lehmhütten und
so star wars handelt von so einer
mischung aus
technik und magie und allen möglichen
krempel und tunen der wissen planet
handelt tatsächlich davon was das
eigentlich ein verhältnis ist zwischen
einerseits einer natur die jetzt nicht
auf uns gewartet hat um uns irgendwie
glücklich zu machen und andererseits
eine technik mit der wir das überbrücken
wollen und drittens dann der hirn
inhalte oder der vorstellung die wir
brauchen um diesen unterschied irgendwie
im leben klar zu kriegen das kann der
religionen seien es keine mystik sein
dass bei den stars sind es die cd
mit ihren mini koreanern indien sind es
die manager schritt das ist ein norden
der eigentlichen darwinistische
zuchtprogramm hat pipapo also der
hauptunterschied zwischen star wars wenn
der herr der ringe jetzt mal weglassen
weil da geht es einfach nicht um die
zukunft der hauptunterschied zwischen
star wars und jun ist der wenn man sagt
beides ist im grunde ein riesiges spiel
für ein kind ja es hat fantasie dann ist
da raus so entstanden dass jemand
einfach eine tüte mit spielzeug auf dem
teppich geschüttet hat ritter polizisten
roboter raumschiffe alles mögliche der
schlug hast ja das alles erfunden hat
gibt es auch zu er hat sich damit die in
der sich dort bedienen französische
comics irgendein buch von campell über
mythen und so weiter und dann ist das
halt so wie wenn kinder sagen mensch
nimmt den roboter und der greift den
cowboy an ok go während im gegensatz
dazu tun herbert hat sozusagen von hand
schachfiguren geschnitzt hat ein
schachbrett erfunden hat spielregeln
erfunden hat eine story erfunden und es
braucht schon einen dennis wilms um
dieses schachbrett das wird zu noch
mehrere ebenen hat tatsächlich in seiner
action zu zeigen wie dieses spiel dann
abläuft wie diese intrigen ablaufen wie
dieses diese balance zwischen der
raumfahrer gilt die droge haben will und
zwischen adelshäusern die um miteinander
im krieg liegen die dreckigen hakens die
wirklich übels sind und die aufrechten
art riders dann gibt es den kaiser
selbst dann gibt es irgendwie noch eine
handels föderation usw also das ist
alles bis ins kleinste durchgeplant als
eine welt und dadurch eine spielwiese wo
man sehr viel präzisere spiele spielen
kann dh der wilders muss sich nur noch
um zwei dinge sorgen machen ist es
technisch ästhetisch geil genug das
heißt ist der sandsturm wirklich so dass
er diese unis ob diese diese fahrzeuge
die sie da haben wirklich beschädigt hat
man den eindruck man sitzt da drin und
es rumpelt antwort ja und das zweite ist
passt die besetzung passt das was mit
den figuren passiert so einander und
auch das hat er ziemlich gut gewesen der
sohn des herzogs sie zu viel
das ist mein junge wollte sie alle
der thematische lamey der den jungen
paula 3 des spiels unseren luke
skywalker sozusagen für die ganze
hilflosen ist auf eine art geeigneter
als die leute die das bisher gespielt
haben es gibt ja eine fernsehfassung und
es gibt einen film von david lynch von
19 84 sicherlich ist agent cooper aus
twin peaks der geileres schauspieler der
den powell gespielt hat bei lynch aber
dieser teils überforderte teils bockige
und teils irgendwie rührende thematisch
alami ist der bessere paul weil das ist
die figur paul und ich habe ein paar
kritiken gehört und gelesen wo es heißt
ja das ist ja wieder so ein messias
klischee und der weiße gleiche junge
rettet uns alle naja jetzt sollte man
den film bisschen genauer angucken das
wird keineswegs rein irgendwie gefeiert
also der hat zum beispiel ein paar
zukunfts einblicke wo er dann irgendwie
eine ganz kalt es sei ist die diese
macht die ihm zuwächse durch diese
retterrolle für grauenhafte völkermord
artige geschichten missbrauch da war der
angst man weiß nicht kommt das kommt das
nicht im zweiten band vom buch
vergleicht er sich weil die archive
offen sind mit dschingis khan und hitler
das heißt es es geht nicht darum das zu
feiern dass da einer kommt der ist dann
checkt sondern es geht vielmehr darum
wie gehen die menschen drum herum damit
um dass es vielleicht doch wer ist da
ist zum beispiel zehn daher eine
wichtige figur die cerny das ist eine
von den leuten die auf diesem wüsten
planeten zu hause sind die so ein
skeptisches und dann nicht skeptisch
sind ein liebendes und was auch immer
verhältnis zu ihm hat wo man so ein
bisschen sieht wie sieht es eigentlich
mit denen zu erlösen den menschen aus
ist es immer die lösung das dann erlöser
kommt also die besetzung ist klasse
nein
danke kann ich dir etwas anvertrauen
immer das weißt du ich habe häufig
treiben
mädchen noch
fragil ist auch dass die fortschritte
der tricktechnik
will noch dazu gebracht haben sich
gedanken zu machen was kann man denn
jetzt machen was man nicht da machen
konnte und was mehr mit dem zu tun hat
was jetzt auch wirklich los ist bei
david lynch sind diese schutzschilde die
die leute haben elektronische
schutzschilde wenn sie kämpfen sind so
früh videospiel polygonen kästen um die
leute rum weil ich meine so war das halt
mit den ersten computer spielen bei
villeneuve ist es so ein zittern so
wahrscheinlichkeit zittern im sinne von
ich will nicht dass meine identität
gestohlen wird deswegen bin ich
irgendwie unscharf und ungenau verwischt
das heißt wir sind computertechnisch
inzwischen weiter aber wir sind auch
weiterhin was heißt eigentlich ein
sicherer raum was heißt eigentlich
sicherheit was ist eigentlich sicherheit
wenn ich nicht zu packen bin und nicht
wird nicht nur eine mauer um mich herum
habe lauter so kleiner kram es macht
einfach spaß
in unserem special
vernichten meine familie ein nach dem
anderen
das als comic zu machen und im grunde
sogar das als fernsehserie zu machen wo
man ein bisschen platz hat oder das als
buch zu machen hatte immer den nachteil
dass ein teil von ich erzähle etwas von
einem ganzen planeten immer dazu da war
die leute zu erschlagen dass es immer um
monumentalität ging wo wenn ich im kino
und wo wenn ich in diesem boom kino dass
wir jetzt ja eigentlich haben und wann
wenn nicht nach diesen anderthalb jahren
wo wir dachten ist es jetzt weg kommt es
zurück so also kannst ja gern irgendwie
skeptisch sein solchen sachen gegenüber
aber ist es nicht schön dass es wieder
da ist also was ich sagen will ist man
sollte sich das buch anschauen und man
sollte den film lesen oder als beides